[Music]
is there anyone who has not used
LinkedIn okay no one is trying to escape
from all these companies who are
tracking you so if you haven't looked
familiar with this page so if you look
at all the things that are available on
LinkedIn so you have a member you have
jobs you have ads post company course
most of you're familiar with all these
things but there are these tiny little
numbers that you can probably is hoping
probably not so you can see some of the
numbers out there and all the analytics
that you can see on LinkedIn so today
what we are going to talk about is how
do we generate all these analytics out
of all the things that you guys do on
LinkedIn so let's look at what are we
actually what is someone doing it on
LinkedIn most of the time so the entire
LinkedIn activity is modeled in an
active verb and object model so you can
think of a user Aris a recruiter or a
representative as an actor and a verb is
basically what you do on LinkedIn so you
might either comment on something you
might like an article or you can do any
of these these actions on one of these
objects right this is this is basically
the fundamental unit in terms of how
activity is tracked on LinkedIn in fact
this is so important if you if you
followed the recent news LinkedIn even
added a few more things that you can do
so you can now like celebrate love
insightful curiousness so all these new
things have come up and this is like
really the bread and butter and lot of
things are built on top of this so
today's talk is mainly about this on how
do how does LinkedIn take all this data
that is coming in from various different
users and how do we convert all these
things into beautiful products that help
growling help LinkedIn grow so the most
the ultimate goal of any company is to
basically get into this everlasting life
cycle which is you build products the
product generates data and you use the
data to generate more insights and last
but not the least you use those insights
and create more products
so you are always in this cycle and
you're generating more and more
engagement better better products so
this is exactly what we did at LinkedIn
we use this data and if you if most of
you might be familiar with this if you
have used any charts at LinkedIn on
LinkedIn which is who viewed my profile
or publicly or published an article and
if you looked at how many shares where
did it come from
all these slicing and dicing feature
most likely you're using something
behind the scenes which is P know so P
know pretty much powers almost 50 plus
site facing applications on LinkedIn
more or less 33 players are real
real-time so if someone looks at your
profile you immediately get to know that
there is someone else the attic
basically goes up and then you get the
slicing and dicing on the data and you
have talent intelligence which allows
you to look at how the competitors are
doing what is the distribution of your
workforce and all these things so you
have millions of Records here terabytes
of data all these things are powered by
you know there are also a lot of
internal products that are powered by
Pino so the experimentation platform the
anomaly detection and also lots of
internal other internal apps are also
powered by about four by Pino a quick
Android about me for those of you just
got in so I pretty much worked on a lot
of Apache projects and these are some of
the projects that I've created over time
but LinkedIn so Apache Hilux is the
cluster management framework used to
build a lot of various distributed
systems you know is the ole up data so
that I'm we talking about today
espresso is the document store at
LinkedIn which pretty much stores all
over all the profiles and it's the
source of truth third eye is another
project that I recently started working
on which is which helps you do uh
nomally detection and root cause
analysis on top of all the time series
data recently I left I left LinkedIn on
last year December end of last year and
I wrote this article and I have to
confess this was the first time I
actually published an article on
LinkedIn in in seven yes and he just
took seven years for me to publish this
so it was it was a really wonderful
journey for me at LinkedIn and I loved
every bit a bit of it and I really had
to write this to just express my
gratitude to LinkedIn so you kind of get
all these analytics once you publish
your article in LinkedIn so you know how
many people viewed it's it's very funny
that a lot of people from Google viewed
it then LinkedIn but that's what the
data says then what I think and then
where did they come from what are their
geo locations and things like that so
the first thing that I will basically
take up with how did we actually come up
with this what happens behind the scene
to power such a thing so in case you've
in your company you have this Activity
Stream activity data that is coming from
your users what can you do with it and
how do you build a product that can
actually take the data and build more
products so the use case the first use
case that I'm going to talk about is
providing analytics on this article
views so let's start with the simple
premise you you have a user who is
looking looking at an article or he
might view it you might like it share it
do whatever our actions that I mentioned
earlier the first thing that we have is
you have a stream that is just saying
someone liked something right that's
that's pretty much the way every
activity or event is represented in
LinkedIn so the traditional approach of
solving this is you take this data put
it into a database you might have
something like a member ID action and
article ID so it's like what kind of
action did you perform on this I on this
article so you have the member ID and
you also have the time
so the other thing that you need to have
is on the other side because you need
how to slicing and dicing by the
industry or where did he come from what
kind of skills does he have which
company does he work on that's not
available in every event because that's
too much to put in every event so you
typically have a member profile which
stores this is where in at LinkedIn this
is stored in Nespresso where you have
all the attributes of the member who
viewed your or your article so the
solution is very simple but this is kind
of how the old old school or even today
for if the data is not really large you
can actually get by with this where you
have an app you do a join on the fly so
the query is slightly complicated but
you can you can definitely figure out
you say hey how do I join between the
two you join on the member ID you pull
the attributes of the member and then
you you are able to group by the
industry and then you get one of the
widgets that I showed in the previous
screen this works very well the couple
of problems with this is it you can get
real-time depending on the kind of
storage that you use here so some of the
storages you should be able to keep up
ending it and then it should work and
some of the cases you'll have to do a
batch upload into these databases but
the other thing that is really a big
cornice it's the latency is very high
because it's doing their join and and
then if you look at the article and if
an article is very famous and there are
a lot of popular articles out so then
it's doing a lot of lookup joints across
the two and then it has to scan through
lot of articles to say that what is the
what is the number of views that it
guards or do slice and dice on that the
second option is little bit complicated
but I'll walk you through that so the
first part is exactly the same you get
that data you put it into the activity
stream and then instead of directly
putting it into the DB you kind of join
the data prior upfront so there is a
stream processing framework that you put
in the middle where you are doing a
look-up on as the event is coming in not
at the query time so you're kind of
shifted your four
or the workload from real-time to
Rangers time right so that's a key
difference that you want to take take
away from here so you you look up the
data wave member table and then now you
ingest another event in to this now this
event actually contains everything that
you need it contains the member profile
and all the attributes of the member
along with along with article ID and the
action and now the app is quite simple
it doesn't involve any join but can just
go through directly query on this single
table and it should be able to aggregate
and the latency part then the first
thing the good thing about this is it's
a near real-time injection the second
part is I've mentioned it a low latency
here but again I put an Asterix on that
it's unpredictable
the reason is now your cost or the time
is proportional to how many how many
rows you are scanning to compute your
answer right so that's where I output I
will get back to this on how pino
addresses this but you can think of if
the article is not very popular the time
taken to show the analytics is not going
to be a lot but if it is very popular
there are definitely lots of things
especially the ones that ask for a
puzzle with how do you answer that that
has a lot of comments and article alikes
so those are going to take a lot more
time to answer the query the third is
taking it to the next level where you
want to like get really really good
latency but what we do here is you pre
cubed so that means you are more or less
computing the answers that you want out
front so the only subtle difference
between the previous one and this the
previous one was just joining and then
storing the data as it is so you can
think of one record for every activities
that you get but in this one record for
every activity is fanned out into
multiple records because now your pre
computing for or pea cubing for all the
different dimensions you might have one
row for the geo one row for industry one
row for so you are having a lot of
fan-out so the problem with this is you
are definitely adding lot more storage
so that's the problem here which is it's
very fast because most of your lookups
is just a single row Luka so your
latency
very good and this is something that
people do use like Kylene is for one for
example one of the systems that does the
P cubing and it's it's very fast but the
problem with this is it's very hard for
you to get real-time in this because you
you typically need to end up batching
batching the data and because you have
to agree gate it and the the premise is
that for every unique combination there
is just one row and of course the the
storage is going to exponentially
increase as you add more dimensions any
new dimension so tomorrow I say that I
want to slice by the browser that the
user was using or something or some
other dimension you pretty much have to
reboot strap everything and the query
capability as well is not good because
now you cannot do slice and dice or any
kind of complex boolean expressions you
can just simply do an and so it is
limited in terms of query functionality
so typically if you want to build
something like this you have all these
options that you can pick and depending
on the scale and how far holes where do
you think the product going you can pick
one or the other but I will kind of
summarize on what is that you will lose
or gain in terms of picking up all these
solutions so the leftmost part is where
you started is the traditional solution
where you would pick the join on the fly
right so the flexibility is huge there
it's amazing you can pretty much run any
any sequel query on it but the problem
with is latency so the complex the query
gets the latency is higher so you will
not really be able to solve this on a
site facing use case as you move along
this axis so now you have the ability to
just do a pre join and a pre agree gate
so the latency is getting much better
here and but the flexibility is your
slightly slowly losing all the
flexibility because now you cannot
really do a joint so you are just doing
a single table query so the systems on
the left side presto big query redshift
they are all amazing in terms of giving
you full flexibility they are all they
store them as the raw table you can
query them but you can't really expect a
sub millisecond latency of
millisecond latency which is what is
required or a strong p99 value on the
middle part you have something like
Pinot druid elasticsearch in flux DB so
all these are definitely the possible
solutions that you can pick up today and
if you go all the way to the right this
is basically where I where you pre cube
everything and then you can store it as
it is so I put Pinot and this as well if
your noticed so I put Pinot in two
places I will get again I will get now
as we get later into this session we
will see why I have put Pinot in both
the places but this gives the crux of
what we can gain and what we what we are
going to lose as we pick any of these
solutions so at LinkedIn once we put all
these things together this is exactly
how the architecture looks like so as
the streaming solution we are we use the
cough car the the play LinkedIn is the
place where it originated and then for
the stream processing we use Samsa so
that's where we look up espresso
espresso is our database where we store
all the member profiles and then it
creates this new event which is the
joint activity event and then puts it
into Kafka and then you know consumes it
and then you kind of get article
analytics on top of that the app just
simply queries Pino so what you saw
there in the first it's basically
powered by Pino and we have two years of
retention but this is something that is
configured configurable whatever the
product decides and sometimes we might
choose to just keep it for longer but
kind of lose some of their dimensions
and do some roblox so that was the first
part of the thing where ice talk if you
look at the lifecycle of you basically
had the data and then you kind of
generated a product and now you can also
think about can we do better how can we
use this data in a much more interesting
way than just showing it to the user can
we our self use it so one of the cool
things that you can actually do with
this data is you can now rerun our feeds
because as you see the feed is always
like a two side
then grudges as a member I'm going and
looking at it and the article is another
side so you have as a member who comes
and you have all your connections and
you have all the articles that your
connections have written or shared which
ones do I show you right so that's where
the feed matching or the ranking
algorithm comes in so my simple option
is to just take all the feeds dump it
and then show it to you or we can
rewrite it so this is where the second
part comes in which is can we use all
these attributes of the user and the
article and then re-rank the feeds right
so you can look at all these different
things like the sum of the numbers how
many views clicks or what is the age
category and all those things of age or
fanatical
so you can see all these things and then
rear ank your feed in terms of getting
so one of the cool things in this is we
we saw a huge increase in our engagement
rate because of free ranking because now
it's not static but it's looks at how
many times you have even viewed the
article so if you have already viewed it
then it's automatically hidden from you
and then you are showing in your new set
of articles so every time you come to
LinkedIn home page you might be seeing
more interesting verticals so the
architecture is pretty much exactly the
same right so because the only key
difference that if you look at it in
this is the green things that you are
showing is seeing in this which is the
article data and the article table so
now earlier it was just looking at the
member table to do the join now we are
getting the additional features from the
article itself which is which category
did it belong to what was the age of the
article so that's where you have and the
other thing is when you push the event
to the kafka you are now having
additional attributes about about the
article so the query looks something
like this and as I said one of the key
things that is super important for us in
terms of solving this analytics use case
is the latency so we have almost close
to 6000 queries coming in so this is not
really heard of in terms of analytics
use case so think of analytics but
solving OLTP kind of workload right so
we have 15 the 50th percentile is almost
like as low as 5 milliseconds for us to
do something like this and then we have
a very strict SLA of 100 milliseconds
and we cannot really miss that in terms
of because feed is really one of the
most you know one of the first things
that you do as you log in to Li log into
LinkedIn
most of you might have heard of Pinot as
Pinot and druid druid is very popular in
this way in this particular space so a
lot of times I get this question of why
did why didn't we use druid why did we
build Pino so the basic premise of why
Pinot started at LinkedIn was to
actually serve the site face in use
cases and if you look at it even today
druid is not really built for the site
face in use cases so it's it's very good
for the internal analytics I'll come to
that in the next section
but Pinot has lots and lots of
optimization which is very very very
much geared towards handling the site
facing high throughput at low latency
traffic so some of the key things that
we have in built in we know that
attributed to this performance
difference is one is the sorted index
the other one is the per query optimizer
so we have this concept of optimizing
the query based on the segment metadata
so for every segment every small set of
data the query can look very different
it's very different from the traditional
sequel databases where it's only the
logical plan that is optimized in P no
we actually optimized even the physical
plan and we also have the concept of
optional indexing unlike Druitt which
needed indexing for every field Pino
doesn't really need it because it has it
knows how to optimize whether it's
depending on the metadata of the segment
so that's the first part which is how do
we take this data and then generate more
product you know more products and show
it to the users the second part is what
can the internal users do with this data
right what are the business insights
that we can get with the same set of
data that we generated so what we have
is not a tool in internal to LinkedIn
called as Raptor which generates
dashboards and insights for pretty much
every metric every business metric are
doing time so we have almost close to
10,000 business metrics that Arjun
generated on a daily basis and it's the
same data so now if you look at it you
can look at where are the clicks coming
from the views coming from by different
countries so the dimensionality is much
much much richer than what we have on
the site facing so another thing that
you can look at which is what how how is
the grouping by different industries
there any change in the trend is it
coming from software software industry
or is it from real estates like what is
the distribution and how is it over time
so these are this is something that is
used extensively at LinkedIn internally
similarly where did we get the views
from where who is the reference so there
are lots of different dimensions I won't
get into the details of that but the key
thing is we have this ability now to do
the same thing for all that if all the
various metrics at LinkedIn so these are
all the business metrics that internal
people annal look at analyze and then
draw some insights and then they even
look at is there a problem with these
metrics whatever can be improved and on
things like that there are like bunch
lots and lots of data here and you have
the ability to do slicing and dicing and
then roll up and drill down
so the architecture here is slightly
different but it's more or less exactly
the same in terms of the only key
difference here is you don't really need
real time in this we do have for some
use cases but it's a no kind of an
overkill to have business insights in
real time for the internal internal
folks for all the metrics for the key
business metrics we do have the internal
of a real time support that pretty much
looks like the exact architecture that I
showed earlier but for the offline use
cases we have the two sources of truth
so we have Kafka and we have espresso
and the data comes into HDFS why I tool
called Goblin so that's the ingestion
framework at LinkedIn and everything is
dumped into HDFS then we have this
pretty cool framework called ump which
is centralizes all the metric definition
in the computation so the dashboards
that I showed earlier
all those things were simply expressed
in a language which is we use either
spark sequel or it can be Pig and you
define the logic and you define you
define the metric here you say what are
all the dimensions that you need in this
metric how often should it be computed
and what is the retention I call all
those things and then umpa just simply
computes all these things on a daily
basis or on a regular basis and then
pushes Sydney to Pinot and then you have
the UI on top of it so the previous
screens that I showed you they were all
coming from coming all the data is
coming from Pino and computed in ump
stored in Pino and then UI the Raptor is
the the UI where you sell the dashboards
so so this is another comparison between
Pino and druid in this particular case
so we basically took all these queries
and then we we ran it across Pino
Android as you see the p50 and the p90
is not too much of a difference and this
is not really seen by a human ready for
milliseconds versus 136 which is for a
human in terms
dashboarding application it's not that
big of a difference but as you see the
total time that it took for Pino to run
the same set of queries is almost half
of what it took for druid so there is a
very interesting thing that you want if
you can see at a meta level which is if
you look at the same cluster now you can
actually perform lot more queries using
Pino than and through it so but if you
look at a single query and then if you
just look at the response time there may
not be too much of a difference in terms
of the perception from a user all right
on to the next how are you doing on time
so the next part is lo que não we have
all these dashboards do we want people
to keep coming and looking at this
dashboards on a daily basis because
they're just looking sometimes for the
trend or for some one homilies and
things like that what if you
automatically do that for them like so
this is where we this is the project
that I was being I was working on I just
called a third eye so this is we built
an anomaly detection framework on top of
the same data where we are showing the
as the dashboards we can automatically
start monitoring all that data so
typically the what people do for anomaly
detection is the Builder streaming
solution which is you stream the data
and you compute the models and then you
you compute anomalies on top of the data
so third eye is a very different
architecture we actually use P know as
the streaming engine so we stream the
data directly into P know the data is
available and then the anomaly detection
is just a stateless system which we
simply queries P know regularly and then
looks at the time series data and then
computes the anomalies so in this we
this is this provides two things one is
the anomaly detection and the second one
is what we call it as root cause
analysis so if there is a problem there
are two ways to solve look try to do
this root cause analysis on that one is
you can have some hypothesis based on
your previous things you might say oh
the issue was in us last time or it was
in this browser or based on your prior
experience and then you try to do
slicing and dicing at this point you are
basically guessing where the problem is
so this is a completely different way of
looking at the problem so if you look at
it on this side we have we just go over
the entire data and then be able to look
at all dimension in what at once and
then in one shot we are able to say
where the problem is coming from so the
heat map is is helping you guide guide
you towards the things that I have
issues so in this case there was an
issue which is there was a I think there
was an increase of 5% week over week on
this article and we want to know where
is this coming from right so we have so
many different dimensions how do we look
into that so here it's pretty obvious
that you just look at the the dark the
big one which is blue and then the nice
thing about this UI is you can click
click each cell and then you can deep
dive and then you can go into the next
dimensions as well so it's very
interactive so it's it's like sub second
latency here even if it is doing all
different dimensions so if you look at
it it's not one query that is required
that is you need multiple queries to
render this something like this so for
every dimension you can think of a
different query and then you have to do
a group by on differ across different
times so it's a lots of queries that are
running but with the ability that we
have an Pino week we are able to even
solve this so what's the challenge
behind the scenes right so it's very
easy to do an anomaly detection at the
top level because you are just looking
at the aggregate sum of that matrix
but the multi dimensional anomaly
detection is much more challenging
because if you kind of unroll it this is
how the loop looks like because now you
want to try out is there a problem with
any different any combination of issues
because sometimes you look at the top
everything looks good you may not really
see an issue that is oh there is a
problem with Android that may not really
surface on the top so you want to do all
these combinations so this second part
is definitely challenging right because
you are now I didn't try to look at all
different combinations here and there is
no one key column where you can
easily look at a subset of the data you
have to pretty much scan the entire data
to compute the segregation
I'll give you a very small quick example
here on why this is hard so if your
query was let's say you are trying to
detect anomaly in u.s. you have to
pretty much can like depending on
assuming most of the clicks and the
reviews are coming from us even though
you have an inverted index inverted
index will only help you find where or
all the rows for us but the scanning
which is the second part of aggregation
which is the second part involves
scanning all these all these rows and
that's going to be slow but the same
query for Ireland will actually be
pretty fast because there are not many
views that are coming from from Ireland
so that leads to the second the lab the
part that I was saying that I will get
to it later which is the space-time
trade-off like if you try to look at all
these solutions whether it's P Q or P
joint or pre aggregated it's really
trying to trade-off between the two
things which is your space and latency
so the OLAP or the columnar source like
P node in sort of druid and P node which
is the similar in the similar form as
druid without the star tree index that
I'm going to talk about basically sits
there which is the latency can be
variable depending on your input so for
example in the previous query you s can
be very slow Ireland can be fast so you
have a lot of variability here and in
the other end you have this pre cube
solutions which is which pretty much the
latency is very good because it's more
or less looks at a morals becomes a look
up but then the storage is very high
because your pre computing a lot of
things so as the number of dimensions
increase you the storage cost increases
drastically so you have a steep curve
here
so what pino added is concept of what is
called as a star tree index where it
allows us to be somewhere in between so
it can we can either go to that extent
or we can be in this extent so without
getting into the
it's a smart database data where
pre-computation so for example in the
previous case where I mentioned about us
it looks at the data and then it figures
out automatically that hey you if you
ask a query for us you have to scan so
many rows so I'm going to actually pick
compute only for us but not for Ireland
because typically the explosion in the
peak you bring comes because your PQ
being for every combination without
knowing it's is going to be expensive or
not so the kind of Pino now becomes this
hybrid solution where you can either go
to all the way to this extent which is
super fast or where play very similar to
draw it which is just keep it in RAW
format or you can have this knob which
says for any given query what is the max
number of rows that I can scan so the
configuration is really based on you can
say that hey for any given query in this
form of a equals some value and B equals
some value I should never scan more than
10,000 records so 10000 is basically
your key there and that allows you to is
the configuration part and that allows
you to get the trade-off between how
fast you want the queries to be or you
want to don't want to compromise on the
storage space so you just let it be in
infinity so if you kind of look at that
that the left side is basically infinity
that configuration and the right side is
basically 1 which means for any query
that I ask don't don't even scan more
than one which comes to the the key
value part so this kind of shows the the
impact of that because now we are able
to run the anomaly detection and the
dashboarding all of this on the same
data set so if you look at it here you
know with inverted index we could not
really scale more than 10 queries per
second with this data just with inverted
because lot of these once you start
having anomaly detection which becomes a
machine generated query so the load is
much higher but with star tree we are
now able to get a lot out of the same
set of machines right so that's the key
difference you may not really see a
difference on a per query basis so but a
lot of these small small differences add
up and or or
a large set of data you can see a pretty
big significant change
now the architecture is very similar to
the Raptor the only thing that gets
added is the third eye on the top on
this end which is the nice part about
this is you know it's the same data that
is doing anomaly detection and the
visualization in terms of dashboarding
so you don't really have this opera how
to operate all these different systems
and there is no data inconsistency this
saying that oh I detected an anomaly in
this but then now we're going to go and
look at the data it's something
completely different
so all those operational challenges are
removed you know usage outside so this
is so uber is a big big time user of
Pino so they have a lot of side facing
applications of if if any of you has
used uber eats the restaurant manager
actually gets this dashboard for him to
look at the analytics on all the
overrides and that's powered by Pino
then a lot of internal things at a tuber
marketplace uber pool uber fried jump
all of them are powered by Pino on the
back the other thing is slack so slack
is a one of a one of the users as well
so they were using Pino druid earlier
and if you look at the message from them
they basically moved from a 45 GB 45
note to 18 note and they still have a
lot of capacity so that is what I was
always referring to that you can
actually get a lot more out of the set
of boxes that you have from P nodes and
to it it's funny both slack and
Microsoft teams both of them use Pino
so um conclusion side I think the key
takeaway that I would like you guys to
think about is all of you have most of
you have this activity data and then
lots of varying kinds of applications
that you want to build on top of it you
might have a site facing application or
internal or anomaly detection and these
applications can become start very small
but can become very popular later right
so the key thing that is most of them do
end up doing is have different solutions
for each of these use cases so you might
use a key value store for one an OLAP
store for one and the stream processing
for another and this results in lot of
operational challenges and having to
build and maintain all these different
systems so our goal is was basically to
build one system with LinkedIn that all
allows us to build handle and take care
of all these very variety of use cases
and that's basically what we what we
were able to achieve at LinkedIn that's
pretty much it I have few minutes of for
questions and then if you are interested
in using Pino at your company feel free
to chat with me I will be able to help
you on what are the things I mean the
documentation part of Pino is really bad
that's something that we are working on
but feel free to chat we have a slack
channel which is active so you will
definitely have the we are also on
Apache Incubator so we will definitely
be able to provide help in terms of
using it that's pretty much it thank you
again
great talk so I had a question you spoke
a lot to the effect of latency in terms
of how long the query is actually taking
to run but then there's another level of
latency I'd imagine from creating these
pre comp these pre computed views if you
were querying like the raw data directly
you didn't have to go go through those
steps of aggregating all the data is
there are there any considerations being
made for the amount of like how behind
quote the data is from when it first
streamed in by virtue of making all
those roll-ups alright anyways it's it's
not a it's not a problem because Pino
provides the real-time injection so it's
it's more the streaming stream
processing engines are also real-time so
it's a matter of few seconds so for
example the profile views that I
mentioned you look at someone's profile
it's
within five seconds it's generally there
and most of the lag is coming from the
Kafka hops in different data centers but
inside of Pinot itself as soon as the
data is in best ingested it's available
for querying I do get the second part of
that which is or we are doing this
joints and is it needed so that's where
you want to have the question for the
product which is what are the things
that you can gain out of making it
really fast from the user by
precomputing it so linkdin is a classic
example where we build a lot of these
applications like 50 plus and the
product managers know the value of how
it drives the engagement back and what's
the value that you're providing to your
customers so it's really a trade off
whether you want to do it for everything
obviously not that's where as I
mentioned we don't really have real time
for all the internal metrics we have
almost 10,000 metrics so only few of
them have real time so it's really a
conscious decision on are you able to
get a value of it we have the capability
maybe there aren't all the use cases
shouldn't be doing that thank you
[Music]
what is the what are the data size of
you were often analytics final DB so we
have more than hundred terabytes of data
for the internal ones because these are
all after some after sometime we roll up
into a day level the real time section
is as I was mentioning for the interval
this much lesser for offline ones we we
keep the daily for almost two three
years and depending on the retention so
it's on this 100 TV after indexing or
before indexing it's after indexing
before indexing it's probably like in
close to a petabyte or something a lot
of compression that you get by indexing
and storing it in the Pinot's the
dictionary encoded format if I may ask
one more question so this 100 terabytes
right are you guys storing is offline
somewhere on this DFS are like no no
pino has its own local storage so it's
stored on the peano service itself it's
now we keep it in offline just for as a
backup but it pulls it in and then it
sort of locally Maps so we map it we
pull it locally and then VM
so how does it fair for so if we have a
use case where you have lot of different
say matrix which has each individual
diamond like Iowa will call us as event
so there you have number of different
type of events which have their own
metrics and dimensions and we have to do
is like aggregation like hourly ten
minutes or a daily aggregation how does
it affairs like is the P note billed for
these kind of use case yeah definitely
so whether you want to do it on the same
table or on different tables that's up
to you so one option that you if you
want to do it on the same table is you
create multiple time columns so one is
on a ten minute roll to that the nearest
ten minutes and the other one is nearest
hour or nearest day and then using star
tree you can it'll automatically create
aggregates for the days and for the for
the ten minutes or four weeks right so
then when you ask for a query which is
for a particular ten minute licorice
then it goes to the subsequent leaf
level otherwise it looks at the higher
level so you get a much better so that's
where it's the per query optimization is
very important so it's it doesn't have
the same plan for every query and that's
where a lot of the performance
improvements that you're seeing comes
from that you have that ability to
optimize on the per query basis one more
quickie and then we get a rapid um can
be pino requires helix as a cluster
manager right yes is there any plans to
support other question managers like
kubernetes and other stuff I think those
are two different I mean I worked on
helix so I can give you a sort of an
explanation on how kubernetes and helix
differ they're actually complementary to
each other
the way you want to look at it is all
these containers I will lifecycle so
they have one lifecycle is just starting
and stopping
that's where kubernetes comes in which
is provisioning and starting and
stopping the container but there are a
lot of other things that happen once
they start
there is a partition and there is a
replication and all those things which
kubernetes doesn't really understand so
that's where helix comes in so if you
look at helix and kubernetes they're
actually complementary to each other
okay so we can use kubernetes for Pinot
but it's independent of whether we want
we don't have to get rid of helix to use
kubernetes so they're all they're
independent of each other
[Music]